right my attractiveness on a scale of
one to ten
hi
hey how's it going my name is shivan i'm
muhammad my name is sanaya and i'm here
to share my secret crush shout out to
sonia
oh you think she's fine
yeah i was about to say the same thing
that's the first time we have
we have the same taste so we thought a
couple of women are fine cool remember
that teacher video you showed me the one
teacher who's fine oh yeah
yeah uh we met in college she
dated one of my best friends for like a
year and a half did your best friend
know not really
that's us what do you mean
he has a crush on a woman who dated his
best friends for a long time yeah
that's us
when you have a crush on somebody that
your best friend dated for a long time
i'm not saying it's inherently sus but
sometimes you just look at that [ __ ]
and waiting yeah yeah of course
you don't decide
this [ __ ] look good [ __ ]
look good
yeah be with your friend and you're
gonna be like hey
[ __ ] look good
nah when you crush on somebody who dated
your best friend and you like very like
intimately romantic about it generally
you just been waiting for your shot i
don't know to me oh the friends sure
yeah sure i look at somebody funny like
that hello hi
hi hi i'm vanessa i'm uriah we have
truth to drink friends edition how do
you two know each other we weirdly met
through my ex-boyfriend yeah do you
still talk to that boyfriend
no
i just like a clean break
the way he's fixated on her and she's
trying to maintain eye contact with the
camera
i advantage you for that
i think you have a great smile i think
you have a good laugh
i really like the way that you like talk
and tell stories i think it's very
engaging oh my gosh that's such a good
confidence
i don't know i just love listening to
you speak hey
all right
i'm good carry on
don't know why i cringe
it's because you can feel how much he
likes her and you can feel it's not
reciprocated yeah if a woman really
likes her compliment she won't go like
oh thanks she don't go oh nice
but we don't know i mean i don't know
but yeah
hey if she reciprocates
[ __ ] i'll give you a hundred that's
that's
no [ __ ] 100 you give me a thousand
listen we're not betting no wrecks oh
yeah we don't got money like that i owe
you a thousand you do yeah hold on
one
two
three
look at all the colorful monopoly money
people are confused
americans are like yo why they got
colored money
all right let's go that's mine
this is not plastic this is so stupid
okay let's just go what happened you
guys didn't see another video we bendy
lost but it was now what are my toxic
traits not taking no as an answer that's
fair
i i i understand like the the want to
like keep your hopes up but like
sometimes like i know is just a no yeah
[Music]
[Music]
okay so this is much more different than
what i thought it was revealing my
feelings to my secret crush uh [ __ ] it
ain't no secret i don't ain't ain't no
secret but
but it's probably because the way the
way he's been acting is so serious bro
that's creepy bro
let me rephrase but don't i think it's
obsessive and it's like at one point bro
just move the [ __ ] on creepy
good we all great creepy
creepy i've been working on improving
but obviously like it's a i've been
working on improving but here we are
how good are you in bed
sell me on your skills
i'ma say i'm a 10. that is a known fact
that is a note that's a note that's
that's that yeah tonight you said you
would care
okay i don't believe you
show me no it's not even that i don't
believe anybody who says they attend no
that's nice because anybody who's
oversold me on these skills has always
been underperformed really yeah yeah
you know what if somebody comes if girl
comes at me she says i'm a six i'm like
oh this gonna be good
because [ __ ] we can only go up from
here [ __ ] unless you sold up your [ __ ]
that [ __ ] don't work [ __ ] we going up
cause we on the bottom floor
how can you [ __ ] up a 6 out of 10.
goddamn if you [ __ ] that [ __ ] up yeah
you must like
just without asking stick a finger in
the nigga's ass to [ __ ] that [ __ ] up
then we go into the basement literally
we're going to the dark places that's
the only way you [ __ ] it up that's the
only six out of ten that's humble and in
the bedroom you should be humble yeah
most people suck yup that's most people
what is
your best position then if you don't
want to answer that question i would say
like the reverse doggy no
no
[ __ ] underrate the the oh my god
wait wait wait they try to be special
with it wait what the [ __ ] is a reverse
doggy
it's your you're on your head
just kidding
about this because reverse
reverse dog put you in the head there's
two options okay you're hitting it from
the back reverse dog you need to either
flip it upside down which is missionary
missionary or reverse dog it means you
flip her around and then she eaten which
is you getting head
and then um you know because i like that
i like the hair pull you get a nice
little like kind of handle grip that way
you know no slips okay
[Applause]
i don't know if this girl's just got a
really good poker face or she's just not
used to being on camera yeah but
she ain't giving me much no what are
your turn ons
i like a person that's very sure of
themselves and their direction in life
ambition family oriented being a
supporter like i have big goals so if
you can't you know like see the big
picture with me then you know it ain't
gonna work so
she's not listening to him she's like
have my baby she she's not listening to
him at all my dudes she nodded but it
went in her head it went
and they saw both of them running
through like poppy fields and babies
like that she's like mm-hmm if he's
single he don't forget that's clear
something about shoulders especially in
like a strong back
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh i feel for this guy this guy's
getting roasted by the internet for sure
rate my attractiveness on a scale of 1
to 10.
uh
uh 110 100.
oh
oh that that that's the sound of a [ __ ]
popping that's what you heard oh
it went like this it went like oh
that's
that's a good sound that's a good sound
i love tattoos and like piercings and
curly hair i'll give you a nine a nine
oh let's go a ten because
the personality just adds
so much to it i'm like a sapiosexual i
love mindsets i'm attracted to that
there's one thing
that [ __ ] online dating made me
[ __ ] hate is the term
sapiosexual
why you know you don't like mine oh you
know i'm attracted to like people
you know intelligence
what do you think somebody out here yeah
i love dumb [ __ ]
man the dumber the [ __ ] the dumber than
the i like that [ __ ] i like a dumb man
hey you know what i noticed too it's
always the driest lamest ass people who
say [ __ ] like they sapiosexual like they
trying to compensate for their lack of
brains by going through their partner
jesus goddamn you went in
why we created sexuality for everything
we call them gold diggers we don't call
them like
currency sexual
i like that what are you talking about i
like that
what are you talking about i like that
i like that that makes sense that's
funny that's so late
hey you know what
uh
i'm a phallus sexual uh you like dick
okay
stop
you like this what are we talking about
hey listen
i'm gluteus maximus sexual yeah
attractiveness on a scale of one to ten
[Applause]
let me say this ordinarily i'd feel
really bad for you
ordinarily you're so clingy but she
doesn't say no to you multiple times and
you're still here so she can't afford to
tell you look good she can't even lie to
you because that'll lead you on so at
some point it's like if you ain't taking
a [ __ ] clue
hey man get what you get
god damn so y'all need to move on
attractiveness is subjective
stop talking stop talking stop i mean
it's awkward have your shot it's awkward
for i get it oh yeah she's trying to
break the tension
if we were to have sex
what would you do to me
oh god
if you get lucky maybe one day
inviting her secret crush and talking
about if you get lucky
hey listen
hey listen i i get it he's here you know
what i mean you have a crush you invite
him on the show but you're still trying
to be a lady
he's here just answer the question just
say straight up hey i'll drain the balls
yeah
say that [ __ ] big paws
okay i'm pretending to be her but they
don't steal parts if we were to have sex
what would you do to me it really kind
of depends on what lead up to it like
what's the energy beforehand and that
really the energy's great the experience
is great you're at the house just wants
to know
i'm out here with this anticipation
a lot of times people be trying to just
rush and go that's what i'm saying like
you got to build up to it you know what
i mean you're not getting nowhere to the
detail that's fine how about this i'll
just show you
what i don't even want to talk i don't
talk about it anyway she's about to show
you she went what no no because you went
no no because she said i like people
that know and are assertive in life i
know where they going
[ __ ] we going what's the sound
oh
he will have it he said i'll just show
you
that's what happened
that's what happened
all the sphincters went oh
this says for me to tell you that i have
a crush on you
i do have a crush on you but i feel like
like i have feelings for you i've been
attracted to you since i think before
you met adam
but before it's like where we didn't
know each other
you're a whole stalker
yeah like you around my periphery i was
interested in you huh
yeah the real reason why i brought you
here was not for
truth or drink friends it was truth or
drink my secret crush because
i've low-key like been crushed on you
since we met yeah but i've never like
wanted to say anything
just because i'm a little shy
that's actually hilarious hey you know
what shout outs to her
shout out to anybody who wants to go out
of the way i think this is a crazy way
to do it like i mean if you're a shy
person going through this whole big
thing but maybe doing something big and
extravagant is your way to overcome your
shyness so i think that's a cool thing
you know irrespective of who's doing it
and how it goes so that's good because
best believe i'll take an l i'm trying
to take an l on national television or
any internet web for millions of people
to see and be immortalized that's a lot
of
yeah that's a lot of reminders of my l
are these feelings mutual why or why not
they're not i don't know i'm sorry
very flattered
but it's like actually it's definitely
extra weird because like
we met through an exploit
like clean break and then like we come
here surprise hey
no i got it
yeah i want to know something funny i
was actually i actually had a day
planner for us after this
i'm [ __ ] you tonight
you know damn well that's going on yo
hey i'm just rooting for my man right
there yeah yeah she probably watching
this video right now be like i'm playing
this boss
are these feelings mutual
i would say
they're not mutual
just because when i work with somebody i
try to keep it you know what it is like
if we work together
i keep it cordial i don't like to mix
business with pleasure technically we
never did any business together that's
what i'm saying so
for me it's kind of like out of the
question even like try and develop
feelings or but there's there's a reason
and i'm just yeah there's a reason why
we're not doing this and it's because
i'm [ __ ] somebody
ah
she getting [ __ ] somewhere so she is
being professional
yeah
could you see yourself falling in love
with me falling in love i ain't gonna
lie when i like somebody i'm assembled
so maybe that's a yes or no
i'm moving to it so you no i said yes or
no
yes you just want to hear one word yes
yes thank you hey you know what
remember when i said this girl can't be
attention line uh
maybe i was wrong
i mean that was intense the wish me yes
or no listen you know for a relationship
probably not for me
but in the bedroom hey
do you want me trying to put your dick
[Music]
did you just want to push your dick
listen that's why
because even though imagining that
listen shut the [ __ ] up i didn't say
[ __ ] no don't talk that yeah you did
what that what is this
i'm asking what you said bro i i didn't
say anything i don't think i said that
we heard it
roll the [ __ ] back
trying to put
that's what you said
play it back
in slow motion please hey man you wanna
put your dick thank you hey listen i
didn't finish that sentence you don't
know where i said put the dick
it could go in the right places plus
what
hey
good for the people who got it right
good for the other people it was a
little bit weird uh for the dude who's
just obsessing like just move the [ __ ]
stop just stop get the clue all right
go go go date go see other people jesus
christ she's not into you what she
describes she's into it's not you you
obsessing over her stops you from seeing
other people and also it's creepy it's
weird
don't do it so that's pretty much it for
me um anything else
let us know what you guys think